here in las vegas though catholic
charities served its annual thanksgiving
feast today this morning volunteers
handed out a thousand thanksgiving meals
to those in need governor steve silac
and other elected officials also stopped
by to lend a hand hector mejia takes us
behind the scenes it took a whole army
to make sure everything was in place by
this morning crews coming in overnight
check this out this is what 20 gallons
of turkey gravy looks like it'll be
poured on top of 500 pounds of garlic
mashed potatoes along with 450 pounds of
turkey catholic charities executive chef
june lau is putting all of this together
with the help of his kitchen staff
preparation you know we we started
really early this year especially with
the pandemic we want to make sure
we have all the stuff that we need the
special mission as it has been for the
last 56 consecutive years is to help
people in need realize they are not
alone on thanksgiving when they come to
our table is
it's maybe the only meal that they may
have for the day so we want to make sure
that they're taken care of being able to
to feel love around you is great around
the holidays volunteers are returning
for the first time since the pandemic
started also new this year guests will
get to eat inside a recently renovated
dining hall a lot of them sleep out on
the street the weather has been turning
cold and i was talking to a couple of
them yesterday and they're just happy to
be inside catholic charities celebrates
80 years in the valley the nonprofit
helps thousands daily through 16
different programs the essentials they
supply also include clothing the weather
is a lot colder than it has been the
last few days so warm jackets are always
needed
socks and undergarments as well
even just warm clothing hector mejia
reporting live local now